a aubervilliers réunion de l'opposition
guinéenne le mouvement des forces vives
commémore les massacres du mois de
septembre et la répression qui a suivi
dans l'assistance des guinéens de toutes
les générations y compris des rescapés
de la tuerie
ont commencé projection des vidéos
amateurs qui ont déclenché un scandale à
travers le monde
ce jour là le 28 septembre 2009 des
dizaines de milliers de partisans de
l'opposition demande le départ de la
junte au pouvoir
vers midi la chasse aux opposants
commence dans et autour du stade
c'était horrible c'était horrible on
aime dit on dirait qu'ils se retirent de
la terre un
noeud pap été pris au piège n'est pas ça
qui règle pas tout mais pas pour
d'austin panique nous étions comme des
gibiers j'ai vu du coup lui des 104
personnes tuées sur place et les femmes
déshabillées qui courait et c'est
inquiétant entouré par les militaires
63 morts selon la junte plus de 400
selon l'opposition et des viols en série
seule aune yare et journaliste lui aussi
est un survivant du massacre depuis
caméra au poing il anime un site web
d'opposition très suivi en guinée contre
la présence de militaires dans le
gouvernement de transition nommé il y à
un mois est-ce que vous pouvez donner
votre sentiment par rapport
cette transition amorcée pour moi il est
mal parti
même loin de la guinée solo se sont plus
utiles à paris qu'à conakry pour
informer ceux qui sont restés
moi j'étais en guinée mais j'étais
presque muselé et je parlais avec des
pseudonymes jets privés dans les
journaux avec des pseudonymes et je je
m'affiche est pas mon boulot c'est
m'occuper que de la guinée je me suis
engagé jusqu'au jour où il y aura une
élection libre et transparente en guinée
voyez on entend aujourd'hui peser de
tout notre poids et pour faire en sorte
qu'en guinée les choses avaient changé
il va falloir qu'il compte avec nous ici
la politique ne se fera plus jamais en
guinée auquel personne ne gouvernera
plus la guinée comme autrefois c'est
fini ça
dans ce hlm parisiens le studio
d'enregistrement du jt de solo un
plateau improvisé chez un membre du
collectif une table de jardin trois
lampes de bureau
[Musique]
solo est l'homme le plus recherché de la
guinée car il ne prend aucun gant il
accuse nommément tout ce qu'ils
suspectent de soutenir la junte
habits du comité de soutien aux actions
du cndd à paris
cheikh amadou seck dit même comité
halim arrêt du mouvement d'un d'histoire
et il est important qu'ils aient des
façons comme ça parce que chez nous
c'est pas tout plaît en fait les gens au
pays et non pas assez de liberté qu'on
peut à loisir
des infos relayées sur plusieurs sites
un groupe facebook de 1500 nombre le
collectif fait feu de tout bois comme
dans un clip vidéo
cible principale moussa dadis camara
l'ancien chef de la junte actuellement
soigné à l'étranger
[Musique]
le chanteur à gauche c'est bill de sam
le rédacteur en chef du journal
l'eau froide on cessera point de le
rappeler mais il faut insister au tour
le collectif continue à exister jusqu'à
la prochaine jusqu'aux prochaines
élections présidentielles une fois que
le premier président guinéen civile est
élu dans ce cas là bas nous arrêtons nos
activités d'activistes et puis nous
accompagnons même nouvellement en place
vers une vraie démocratie
les tarifs se doterait mots
[Musique]
en attendant le collectif ne relâche pas
la pression il écrit une chanson de
soutien aux femmes violées de la
répression une chanson contre les
militaires que le collectif espère bien
voir diffusé sur les radios africaines
[Musique]